bonjour alexis blanc vient d'entendre
bruno bonnell qui et pointe du doigt
l'opposition jean réussite la phrase
emmanuel macron emmerder les
non-vaccinés jusqu'au bout sortie
stratégique et voulu en vue de
l'élection présidentielle ou bien
dérapages aux sorties stratégique est
voulu malheureusement parce que une
interview dans le parisien relu validé
par les services de communication de
l'elysée ou emmanuel macron ici les de
se mettre au niveau 1 de l'homme du
bistrot à vous ne pourrez plus boire de
canon il essaye de parler populaire
emmanuel macron ils changent de costumes
ils s'adaptent au lectorat à ses
auditeurs tout ça pour avancer masqué
est avancé pour détruire détricoter
l'état de droit c'est proprement insensé
d'avoir un président de la république
qui choisit de dire clairement qu une
partie de la population et bien il
aimerait il a envie de les emmerder
jusqu'au bout on ne sait pas ce que ça
veut dire ce jusqu'au bout c'est
extrêmement inquiétant un président ça
ne doit pas dire sa présidence est le
garant des institutions
c'est celui qui est censé assurer la
sécurité à tous les français or là en
choisissant la politique du bouc
émissaire en faisant reposer tous ses
échecs sur les non-vaccinés qu'il montre
du doigt il les offre à la vindicte
populaire comme étant une sous catégorie
de citoyens c'est ignoble la
constitution française site avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme que
les hommes naissent et demeurent libres
et égaux en droits avec emmanuel macron
c'est fini il y en a qui vont se faire
emmerder et qui n'auront pas les mêmes
droits et cela comme si c'était tout à
fait normal l'ours est absolument
anormale inacceptable dans un état de
droit dans une république comme la
france rappelons la devise de la
république liberté égalité fraternité
emmerder plusieurs millions de français
c'est la rupture du pacte républicain
rien de moi que propose emmanuel macron
fort de ses 90 % de français vaccinés
qui penseraient comme lui or il est là
en train de flatter des atavismes des
passions tristes comme il aime à le
montrer du doigt chez ses adversaires un
président c'est tout sauf ça on a là un
emmanuel macron candidats quelqu'un qui
n'a plus à gouverner qui n'en est plus
capable c'est extrêmement dangereux
parce que politique du bouc émissaire si
vous la suivez jusqu'au bout c'est
potentiellement la guerre civile c'est
potentiellement un bain de sang on se
souvient du j'entends ceux qui
manifestent mais j'entends aussi ceux
qui ne manifestent pas de dominique de
villepin à l'époque emmanuel macron est
ce que là il s'adresse à sa base
électorale quitte à cliver et quelles
conséquences dans les sondages
oui clairement il est là il a fait son
calcul pour être le candidat des
vaccinés contre les non vaccinés qui
emmerdent les français et puis avec ce
projet de société harmonieuse presqu'à
la chinoise ou le bon citoyen aura son
pass et le mauvais citoyens de leurs
appâts christophe castaner d'ailleurs le
disais à demi mot se passe vaccinale
lille n'est pas à propos du vaccin il
est à propos du certificat de
citoyenneté vous êtes un bon ou un
mauvais citoyen selon que vous obéissez
aux décrets d'emmanuel macron aux lois
du parti unique qui serait la république
en marche on marche sur la tête les
oppositions elles sont là pour débattre
démocratiquement or que disent les
responsables de la république en marche
quand il montre l'opposition qu'ils sont
irresponsables et que dit emmanuel
macron que les irresponsables ne sont
plus des citoyens il est là en train de
tuer l'opposition il est totalement dans
une dérive libérale il est là pour
mettre à bas l'état de droit et c'est
inacceptable nous n'avons pas à discuter
finalement de ces mots de ce président
un président n'a pas à dire ces phrases
là il vient de rompre le pacte oui
justement vous parlez de l'opposition
qui évoque un tollé à droite comme à
gauche on s'en prend à l'incarnation à
part emmanuel macron de la fonction
présidentielle
malgré le récent mea culpa sur tf1 il ya
15-20 jours une petite phrase qui en
rappelle d'autres emmanuel macron est-ce
qu'il a changé alors qu'on s'approche de
l'échéance présidentielle
il disait le 15 décembre je cite j'ai
appris une chose c'est qu'on ne fait
rien bouger si on n'est pas pétré de
respect infini pour chacun et voilà nom
emmanuel macron il n'a pas changé il est
manipulateur il est mal traitant avec
les français c'est le président de la
violence il en fait encore une fois la
preuve avec ces mots d'une extrême
violence insultant pour des millions de
français mais enfin quel président d'une
démocratie pourrait se permettre de
telles sorties de route c'est
inacceptable il le fait aussi parce
qu'il sait que les oppositions sont
faibles au lieu de déposer sur 10 ans us
face à ce gouvernement et une
destitution une procédure de destitution
de ce président qui est dangereux
maintenant pour la démocratie il sait
qu'il ne se passera rien que les
contre-pouvoirs sont très faibles qu'eux
conseil d'état comme le conseil
constitutionnel le suivent dans cette
dérive libérale sous couvert de crise
sanitaire mais rappelons le cette
gestion sanitaire depuis deux ans est un
échec trois cent mille cas par jour 77 %
de français vaccinés 90 % des adultes
éligibles vacciner et pourtant il faut
encore montré du doigt une minorité ces
boucs émissaires de non vaccinés pour
cacher finalement ce fiasco alors fiasco
à avoir parce qu'effectivement gabriela
talent dit qu'on a plus de cas et moins
hospitalisés heureusement or l'hôpital
est toujours en tension les soignants
n'ont pas été entendus le ségur n'a pas
été à la hauteur et aujourd'hui c'est
les non vaccinés qui sont responsables
de tous les échecs des modèles macro et
il faudrait que le reste des français
les montre du doigt également mais enfin
c'est inacceptable c'est proprement
scandaleux et que vous passez alors
selon moi que tu alors à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que ces propos vont
avoir un impact sur le texte sur le
projet de loi du post vaccinales
j'espère que l'opposition va se rendre
compte que ce pass vaccinale n'a rien de
salutaire qu'il est une mesure
liberticide dangereuses pour nos
libertés et qu'il est une des premières
étapes vers un crédit social à la
chinoise ou une société de la vigilance
a plaidé veut des modèles macron une
société de la vigilance c'est tous les
français qui surveille les autres
français c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus
de liberté la liberté devient une marge
elle n'est plus un bois il parle
d'ailleurs des devoirs qui sont
supérieures aux droits c'est faux dans
un état de droit les droits sont
inaliénables et nos libertés en
particulier aux relations rentrer dans
cette logique de passe peu importe le
nombre d'injections peu importe aussi ce
qu'on y mettra au à l'avenir c'est la
fin de l'êta droit c'est la fin des
libertés donc j'espère que les
parlementaires vont se réveiller de ce
long sommeil de cette hypnose et se
rendre compte du mal qu'ils font à la
démocratie française et quelques
oppositions heureusement ont pris la
parole en a entendu la parole du groupe
de la france a soumises de jean luc
mélenchon de marine le pen également
qu'ils font ce qu'ils peuvent dans
l'hémicycle pour calmer les ardeurs
liberticide d'emmanuel macron mais pour
les républicains où le parti socialiste
qui pensaient s'accommoder de ce pass
vaccinale la question se pose est ce que
on va suivre un président dans ses
délires et dans ses désirs et insulté
des millions de français avec lui ou
bien est-ce qu'on va défendre ces
français qui se sont fait marcher dessus
par un président de la violence c'est
extrêmement important parce que ça va
changer tout à fait la donne si emmanuel
macron prend un camouflet aujourd'hui
c'est sa campagne qui va commencer sous
de mauvais auspices il fera 1 49 3 et ce
sera pire encore ce sera l'aveu de sa
tyrannie tyrannie au sens grec bien sûr
quelqu'un qui prend tous les pouvoirs en
situation de crise exceptionnelle c'est
ce qu'il fait depuis deux ans et c'est
inacceptable
merci alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à
nos questions